the war on terror did little to end
global violence and it has cost a
staggering four point four trillion
dollars but who exactly is profiting
from this war these are some of the key
beneficiaries of Washington's wars since
2001 weapons are big business in
attempting to protect itself from real
or perceived threats the u.s. spent six
hundred and forty billion dollars on
weapons in 2013 alone it's also the
number one exporter of weapons to the
world weapons manufacturers like
Lockheed Martin Boeing and Raytheon and
some of the biggest profit ears in the
ongoing so-called war on terror and
although military spending is slowing
down in the West it's rising elsewhere
to make up for the slowing sales in the
US and Europe defense contractors are
looking overseas today u.s. weapons
manufacturers account for 42% of weapons
sales to the Middle East one way for
those weapons manufacturers to ensure
their lucrative government contracts
continue higher lobbyists lots of them
in 2013 232 defense contractors
including Lockheed Martin and crew spent
a hundred and thirty-four million
dollars on lobbyists to push Congress to
continue these wars you see if the war
continues so do their contracts with the
governments worth billions
hence the cyclical nature of this whole
military-industrial complex the US
government wants to know whether you're
a terrorist have ties to terrorism or
maybe just have the potential to become
one someday they do this by paying
intelligence contractors billions of
dollars to mine your data almost 2,000
private companies companies like IBM
Palin tur and Booz Allen where it would
snowden worked work on programs for 17
government agencies including the CIA
Homeland Security and the FBI of the
estimated 500 billion dollars spent on
the US intelligence budget since 2001
70% of it has gone to private
contractors
other prophet ears of the so-called war
on terror were politicians who were
close allies of the United States in
countries where al-qaeda was known to or
even suspected to have been operating
take for example the former president of
Yemen a man on the good side of the
so-called war on terror former President
Ali Abdullah Saleh has been accused of
using weapons from the u.s. to attack
his opponents the u.s. funded trained
and equipped Yemen's generals many of
whom ended up pursuing corrupt ins
weapons and money were often used to
shore up solace personal power not to
defeat Al Qaeda so if the weapons
manufacturers lobbyists intelligence
contractors and even US allies are all
profiting from the so-called war on
terror do you think it will ever end
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook